goosebumps season X let's do this ladies
and gents where's the battle pass Oh
before we start the battle puss promise
of course because we do this every
season we get 30% personal XP boost Oh
we'll take that thank you
what's this a new item for your
collection and joy pony up everyone oh I
like the tune it's been updated but
techno vibe oh we have a new video
[Music]
oh the toons are so good I feel like you
need Zeke's voice welcome to a new
battle pass his three men dancing anyway
we need to get through this we need the
battle puss
here we go catalysts so she's a female
drift damn girl okay I can get behind
this I can get behind this still six
more stages to go oh cause the Cohen and
they'll be some vibrating colors behind
them one day oh oh there they are
there's all a negative energy and
there's the female drift okay yeah
that's a pretty good start to skin what
else have we got X Lord so we have the
rust Lord version to red looks good
green looks pretty damn good oh there we
go but a sexy man haha look at that oh
he's get a tattoo or wonder if that's a
clue about the future I do like that
I really shouldn't like shirtless men
but I do okay I can get behind this
what's next
our first spray is the rocket from
season was it season for season 3 that
West wish was the rocket
I cannot remember
the red night rocket riding do you
remember those days
damn Daniel they were good that's a
pretty good skin a wrap should I say
alright somebody dancing I'll look at
your clothes it's some of the dance
portraits the eggs we still don't have
an answer for those eggs hang on this
music it's too loud that's better that's
better where were we eggs what can they
mean popcorn that's not a bad contrail
is it here into popcorn the junk bucket
that's damn nice see my only issue with
with these kind of things is if they
make too much noise you know so you
can't really sneak up on anyone whereas
the the umbrellas are perfect because
they're nice and stealthy the frost wing
okay okay so really it just is going
back in time and looking at everything
that's gone before like that was created
by someone look created by hydro 74 so
they're getting the community on board
which is pretty good those three books
we like those be books ah the soundtrack
from the final showdown
yeah I'm gonna use that I am gonna use
that my steamer yeah oh it's a traversal
one yes guys this is the one we're gonna
use in a live stream who can stay alive
the longest by only using this emote
cosmic cleavers okay I can get behind it
if I have to yeah look look created by
Aaron Creighton Creighton so this is
good community involved I like that kind
of thing crack shot there's the the
butterfly the break-in time shattering
fire versus ice which never actually
happened
maybe this season they will actually do
something with fire versus ice wow it's
all pink and beautiful perfect of a
drift bottomless pit
the red knight now has her own rap damn
girl tilting technique oh I do like that
one the purple and white okay I don't
like that one but the purple and white
look good black looks damn good she
looks like she's got a double chin go
back to the other one next oh that
that is gorgeous simple ass gorgeous
more popcorn picture of Gavin there's
the butterfly event oh I know it's based
after drift but my word it looks like
the PlayStation grenade mask
I may have to rock this but the back
blings is so damn big is literally like
carrying an armchair behind you
life preserver the spray sale oh that's
good yeah I can see people using that go
go go go go back go back back 31
traversal yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like wrapping
[Music]
loads of ebooks this season once again
the EQ who animate it how it does it
animate does that mean when you shoot it
how can you test it how can you test it
so I presume when you shoot little bits
of white will fly up the sides like
sound trails damn it we can test it Oh
God so the throw of all this season is
the bottle flip dude okay the sparkle
specialist what a good skin she was not
many people rock that one
Oh even the bags have multiple versions
now
master mix so is that for drift or ease
up no it's DJ yonder that isn't it did
it did it did it did it more artwork
from the fans yeah okay I'm sure we've
already got something like that dares
the pepper kitsune in blue frost version
blowing bubbles they're running low on
ideas now aren't they
and here he is DJ yonder in gold so we
have to unlock him again okay
I wonder if we can take his mask off no
MJ that's the Michael Jackson one I like
it like Ella
risky rails ah is risky reals coming
back one of my favorite spots ever made
oh gee classic music season zero fancy
bottle flip yeah DJ yonder unmasked it
looks like a horse I don't care when you
tiptoe drew what's that guy called
Jason Derulo Jason Derulo wow that is
good Sparkle specialists everywhere this
season I can already feel it
quote the raven nevermore
croissants
the rooms from Kevin hang on
I'm sure I've already bought that wrap
okay
give me a sec
[Music]
on us gemstone
nice storm okay it's different I take
that back
where were we oh wow that's from the 80s
that's an how can I explain it it's a
tea style arts like retro sci-fi you'd
see that in a lot of games tilted map so
probably there'll be two halves to that
and you have to spray it together that's
my guess
more traversal - I am gonna lose so many
games by just traversing through them
all yeah yeah
kitsune in black
overlay heads up diving
will this tell you how far from the
ground you are or is this just some sort
of Tron
esque overlay okay we're going to the
wild wild west the wiki while the wiki
wild with you wild wild west Jim West
desperado Rough Rider no you don't want
none of this some of this I don't know
the [ __ ] words Sparkle Supremes
oh right so all the old skins we have to
get them again so reusing assets and
slightly changing them as clever
fortnight annoying but clever what the
hell is that I'm not sure if I'm with
that there's like a nipple tassels dusty
been devastated oh and the bob cut
look at those bangs
space invaders space invaders what a
lovely Easter egg and we've got some Oh
breakneck stuff what hey you with the
rock steady
I wasn't travursel was it nice nice
[Music]
celestial who is a celestial in THE
AVENGERS
they were the were they the six being of
something which made the power stones
Infinity stones anyway looks good it
looks very good it looks like it goes
with that Samsung skin scavenger yeah we
can get behind that it's noise don't
know that is don't know what that is two
pumps please don't bring double pump
back please don't bring double pump back
because I'll have to switched to bloody
keyboard and mouse
please don't eruption Oh eternal Voyager
bloody hell that looks in brilliant it's
a hell Rider what was the Nicolas Cage
film the Marvel the Marvel comic damn I
like that it's like Terminator 2 on acid
swear to it okay not for me the black
knight with his shield I still love that
shield
an extra style skin what what's the
difference well the Vice is open the
visor has opened hello
how I'm the eternal Voyager more artwork
the steel wing why did I even buy a
bloody dragon if you're gonna give him
away in the battle pass it's worth it
what the heck does that face look like
is it something from Lord of the Rings
oh no no it's an ember main that is prom
Dauntless that face is an ember main I
might flick it up on screen for a split
second now I'm finally maximum drift
that is a nice wrap yeah I like that a
lot Bobby bucks here he is the king of
dusty has returned seedy and the third
and then the Ultima night and I know
where this is from - but will will not
discuss it until later in the season
although it does look like a that term
guy from Lord of the Rings where the
woman kills no man can kill me terrible
impression be I think you know what I
mean the witch-king I don't bloody well
know anyway that's the battle plans what
do you think should we look at some
challenges to shield look at that shield
okay I'm impressed
I am impress doesn't take much to press
me but I am impressed zero point
challenges well we have to wait but we
will get different versions
available with the battle pass can we
look at these oh let's go back to her
hoodie okay so these are just tiny
improvements to characters but what's
the difference a hoodie for her - okay a
random hands dance with a leg tap what's
it called dub stunt I wonder who they
took that from Lobeck oh I really like
this skin and I don't understand why
it's just great I've got a six-pack ABS
in my fridge DJ yonder with a flare just
like you stole some curtains by the way
what and drop
down
supreme disco another overcoat what's
the difference with this one is that
just without the helmet and then so just
more styles just more styles road trip
adventure we'll have to wait for that we
get it back blink and with this one the
Royal sewed the rumble Royale we get
those bad boys chain blades don't know
why and they test sound and then all
these other challenges coming soon oh
yeah I haven't finished it looks yet
from season 8 yeah boy just make sure
there's nothing free it's more raps
what the heck is that that is weird as
hell there's a bag of heads as you do
well suppose you do active chain solve
them off
bugger heads oh that's so good
damn I am gonna be playing a lot this
season
I need those I think we've seen most of
these hey get your little scepter these
are really well-made there's so much to
unlock don't be playing any other games
is what fortnight is saying to us game
plan retro very Galaxian but space
invaders this is brilliant and Ultima
Knight what do you have for us we know
about the steel wing we've seen those
just get a massive hammer why not
I am really impressed with this season
what do you think happy with it sad with
it
glad got AIDS
tell me your opinions I am very happy
with this I'm looking forward to jumping
in and just played a few games but what
I'm gonna do after I've uploaded this
video I am going to do all the map
updates for this season it'll probably
take me hours but in the meantime thank
you for watching please think about
using code a Demario I will give you a
shout-out in the following videos during
the week and this season and this season
everything I make from Mike reporter
creator code will be going straight back
to you guys in live streams so if you
don't have a battle pass yet don't worry
you can win one from me anyway I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade I'll see you
soon